the bernanke museum is the second most
visited in greece after the acropolis
museum
it has a collection spanning 2 000 years
of greek
islamic and asian civilization but it's
in financial trouble
70 percent of its income is from ticket
sales restaurants and shops in its nine
venues
the pandemic has forced greece to close
museums drying up that revenue
so the bernanke asked the living artists
it displays
to contribute works for an online
auction
it gathered 240 priced anywhere between
40 euros and 70 000 and the auction it
says is going well
partly thanks to the museum's clean
record of acquisition
contrary to all the major european
museums this is not a colonial museum
which it was built on love for art
and history it was not built as the
outcome of an imperial power colonial
power
that has gathered all these treasures
from around the world the bernanke is
doing
as much online business as it can
shipping gifts ahead of christmas
but the shortfall it has to cover is
considerable
the bernanke museum needs eight and a
half million dollars a year to keep its
doors open
every month that it's closed it loses
half a million dollars
two lockdowns this year have so far kept
its shut
for five months depriving it of almost a
third of its annual income
and that doesn't include company
sponsorships for exhibitions like this
one
which was due to open on the day the
latest lockdown began
but the benagi's board is determined to
succeed
because this is the only museum that
traces
greek identity through all its phases
from antiquity
through byzantium to the modern state
the bernanke became a depository
of trust for the greek society
and also the greeks of the diaspora that
every single time that they had
something important to donate and
preserve for the next generation
they would rather give it to the
bernanke museum the bernanke then
provided
the binary society vision and content
and over the years we had this
relationship of trust
the bernanke is now calling on that
global community of supporters to help
it survive during this challenging time
john saropolos al jazeera athens